In the book we discover you do have strategies
And think putting people at ease like when you were making the the documentary the porn performers?
oh, yeah, I mean
Well, the idea behind my my serious weird weekends was that I would take part in whatever world I was investigating.
So I made and that was partly just to be funny, but then it turned out to have other advantages
So in the in the episode I made about porn performers
I thought it would be quite funny
if I
Sort of got involved in the world of pornography and and then and then it was a question of how far can I push that?
And so I thought well I can go I'm I can take my clothes off and audition for one of the for the main
Adult film agents and you know, and so and so that's what I did. I took my clothes off
It was you thought you committed to Judy, really
It was not completely, you know
comfortable for me
but I did it the one thing the concession I made was for the
So this agent has an album of Polaroids that he shows directors who come in and want to hire
Talent of course and um and so but most of them like to do it properly
I hope I can use this term on on TV. You're supposed to get wood
That's fine, isn't it?
Yes, that's fine
To show to be able to show the directors basically what kind of-
Tree you have?
A sapling? Or is it a Redwood?
And I and I stopped short I thought you know what my sound recordist and cameraman and director
Needless to say or my mum and the viewers at home. Do not need- no
To see
It didn't make the documentary any worse. No, but they don't you know, what happened as a result though
We shot that early in the process and then thereafter
I would I got the Polaroid like he gave me the Polaroids and so I had three of them and
For some reason I carried them around with me
in my pocket and then
when I was interviewing other well other
performers for the documentary there usually came a point during the interviews where I would take out the Polaroid and say
Do you know what I?
I auditioned for Jim South as well and you know in another context that could be highly inappropriate, right?
You wouldn't do that in a normal workplace. Have a look at that
Wouldn't dream of it
But in that context suddenly the performers saw me as one of them, yeah and it had had a very
Sort of but beguiling effect they relaxed them and they were more comfortable when they saw
the
Birch that the birch
Tree to compare it to no, no, no willow the possibility of wood the possibility
Wood that I had with me and one of the other things I think does make you unique is that when you're filming?
No it was just a metaphor I was just working with one metaphor
The possibility of wood that should be the term
For the next month
You